jetzt geht es auch in der luftfahrt
schlag auf schlag die nasa hat das
design eines überschallflugzeuges
vorgestellt mit dem passagiere in drei
stunden von europa in die usa fliegen
können und ein weiterer hersteller boom
hat gerade 21 millionen eingesammelt um
einen prototypen fliegen zu lassen und
auch hier geht es ganz schnell schlag
auf schlag also passagierflüge mit
überschall endlich wieder ist es
möglich jetzt ein klick zum 26 herzlich
willkommen
dass man das karriereende des rtl-
chefredakteur dieser level i sich mit
einem überschall jet mit der concorde
in knapp dreieinhalb stunden von europa
in die usa katapultieren während sein
chef rtl boss dieter thoma in der
economy class eines ganz normalen
fliegers eingequetscht war was auch an
seinem übergewicht lag und etwa die
doppelte zeit diesen zustand ertragen
musste und das ticket von dieter lösche
war auch ein wenig teurer als das seines
chefs mehr als 20.000 dollar also rund
10.000 euro hat das damals gekostet
dieter lösche flug sodann auch mit
super zeit geschwindigkeit bei rtl groß
die concorde war einfach ein
finanzielles gesagt sei nicht nur für
die passagiere
die entwicklung des passagier jetzt soll
irgendwas zwischen 2,4 und 6 8
milliarden dollar gekostet haben
british airways soll jedes jahr rund 40
millionen dollar verlust gemacht haben
der zivile überschallflugzeug einfach
nur eine katastrophe und endete auch mit
einer am 25 juli 2000 fing eine maschine
beim start in paris feuer und stürzte
ab alle insassen starben
zwar wurde die maschine noch mal
verbessert und startete wieder aber am
zehnten april 2003 war dann endgültig
schluss zu teuer zu unsicher und auch zu
laut viel zu laut seitdem können wir
noch mitunter scharf flugzeugen zwischen
europa und den usa hin und her jucken
doch das soll sich jetzt ändern es hat
sich sogar ein kleiner wettlauf darum
entwickelt wer als erster wieder in
rekordzeit zwischen den kontinenten
unterwegs ist jetzt wie nasa ihre pläne
dazu vorgestellt die weltraumagentur
plant den quiet supersonic transport
also den leiden überschall transport
mit ihrem explain herausragendes merkmal
der überschallknall soll viel leiser
als bei der concorde an dieser knall
entsteht wenn ein gegenstand schneller
als der schall fliegt und der ja
allerdings scheint die entwicklung nicht
ganz glatt zu laufen bisher ist nur von
windkanalversuchen die rede
dabei wird an dem projekt schon seit
jahren gearbeitet 2001 wurde mit der
entwicklung begonnen und jetzt ist man
immer noch beim
von moden ursprünglich sollten die
über schreibmaschinen schon 2014
fliegen und letztes jahr sollte
ausgeliefert werden die website des
ursprünglichen auftraggebers ist nicht
mehr erreichbar alles etwas seltsam wie
bei ihnen macht könnte vielleicht auch
hier wieder der kleine david den
wettlauf gegen den großen goliath nasa
gewinnen auch bei spacex hat nicht die
nasa konkurrenzfähige ergebnis zement
wege sondern ein privatunternehmen beim
überflug heißt das unternehmen boden
und hat gerade 41 millionen dollar
eingesammelt um im wahrsten sinne des
wortes zu starten
2023 sollen die ersten überschalljets
des jungen start up abgeben und das
unternehmen spiel alle drei concorde
probleme gelöst haben der bodenwert
soll nicht mehr zu teuer zu unsicher und
vor allem auch nicht zu laut sein 30
prozent leiser soll das flugzeug seien
schon 2018 sein testflugzeug also ist es
ja ich will ein baby boom abheben lassen
uns von 2023 soll der linienbetrieb
aufgenommen werden und es soll billiger
werden nur 5000 euro soll dann der flug
zwischen paris und new york wechseln
wird durch flugzeuge sind schon von
fünf airlines bestellt die ersten seen
sollen an virgin atlantic dem
luftfahrtunternehmen von richard branson
gehen wird in atlantic wird sich auch an
den ersten test des flugzeugs p1
baby-boom beteiligen gibt noch weitere
unternehmen die sich an dem wettlauf
beteiligen us-flugzeugbauer boeing will
ein überschalljet für 23 passagiere
bauen der auf 2023 den flugbetrieb
aufnehmen soll
hamacher aerospace will ein jet mit 36
sitzen auf den markt bringen hier ist
der jungfernflug für 2025 plant
es ist also eine menge los auf dem markt
für über engagiert jetzt wenn es etwas
neues dazu gibt erfahrt ihr es
natürlich hier drückt mir dafür hier
einfach ein abo aufs auge ist kostenlos
und vergesst nicht den auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit dem hyper lob
und den plänen für deutschland wenn es
euch interessiert einfach draufklicken
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran